[Music]
[Laughter]
so you you when you do your Timmy dude
don't do it to stop him do it to keep
going so you have a contact point you
can turn him but you keep him going easy
keep their balance going off oh oh okay
and look how I'm smothering everything
I'm tiny you see that so in here he
doesn't have the vise nice trompe
between us hey but he can't get in the
knife can you get it with his other hand
no you see so I'm very tight as I do
though the whole technique okay got too
much space in here
well you're not supposed to
[Music]
absorb all
making dismiss you don't need this
he just missed
okay
[Music]
what
whoa
yeah
[Music]
the time is
the disarm is still doing the same thing
seven connection is still doing the same
thing keep its balance going beep it
just missing you add the redundant the
time fula timi hit they can't go like
this your weapon stays between you and
the flight you see don't lose the check
on the arm
[Music]
now if I stopped here right he's he's
being absorbed adhered off-balance okay
so you have to watch your your strikes
like I said you can't do it to stop him
same thing goes on on on your checks so
these are all contact points so as I'm
here I'm yielding the initial energy
same thing goes on the on this contact
point when this bond Zack point is not
given about the balance this contact
point is letting him go into it but it's
not letting come to me so I'm not
throwing in I'm kind of a menace all
or this hitting their get of the float
[Music]
you night here see I'll move the knife
around you see you have it but I'm not
doing this I'm just stuck to it nice the
two swords here okay if you don't have
to stop these scripts how soon get it
Hey HDMI wait we're just using the forms
to understand a different kind of body
than we're used to okay so when he comes
in right and I cut yeah it's it's a
martial technique but I wanted to see
space and timing I want to see the Heike
body and then I also want to see sound
body mechanics okay
so you guys know like this like yeah
you're not becoming your body and then I
tasked you with yes cutting it is a
great disarm what I just I want to see
what your weight on it you understand
hey can you do that or are you like this
and you have no kinesthetic awareness so
I'm over here and then partially this
technique is a combative technique where
you go I'm going to give up something
maybe a lot for getting a lot more yes
you can move all around you get it you
can ground me
you can't kick me you see so I you do
this you do this wait you're fighting
for real you got it easy I'm bracing
right I know that you have a lot of
openings right so I know if it's worth
it because once I cut a thumb off the
grips not there but my body body has to
have that consciousness that you you
have given up a lot so I brace for
impact but that's the same skill you do
it and if you're just here
your body is being pressurized from the
inside okay same thing when you strike
when you connect and here you have to
have a pressure running through your
body so that's what this drill is about
okay so I I'm martially it's empty it's
gonna come alright and he's gonna have
strapped me represent that in his tackle
goes boom okay I'm bracing for impact
I have the pressure I have the skeletal
alignment but psychologically you have
to have it so as you guys are doing it
you're like I am a perfect I woke up and
then you go you go oh because
there's a fraction of a second in there
where you go he got me he got me and
that you can't do that when you do this
kind of Marshall exactly your your your
mind is going to go he he got me head
you're gonna go no yes and did it do you
get it that will is the part of
maintaining the pressure okay
so sometimes I don't know how much
reaching will get here but if I ever get
displaced what should happen is your
entire body just lose not you get
segmented you understand so that's the
drill I'm just here I'm bracing you can
see how my shoulders my head everything
is talking so I have the body so you
have to find a brace for impact so on
there I'm pressure okay but you have to
psychologically have this your you're
thinking it's too much you know my magic
techniques and I don't need my combat
mindset and that's what setting you up
okay let's go
[Music]
you